[Music]
hey yo what up this your boy david lucas
man and welcome to another episode of
flatline man live here from the thick
boy studios man and guess what y'all hit
me hard in the comments keep bringing
them damn jokes bro cause i love it so
i'm gonna read some of my favorite jokes
from last week
and uh you know y'all could step it up a
little bit man you know what i'm saying
get get a little more creative man we
know the fat jokes that's obvious but
get a little more creative but i'm gonna
read something that really stuck out to
me
david looks like the kind of guy to eat
around the vegetables that's decent bro
i hate vegetables
it's broccoli
uh how david looked like patton oswald
and travis scott at the same time
you see you just thinking a little bit i
like that
david looked like he's auditioning for
the role of violet
bureau guard in the bt version of willy
wonka in the chocolate factory and if
y'all don't know who violet is that's
the girl who they said violet you're
turning violet
and willy wonka in chocolate factory
david looks like he knows the seasonal
mcdonald's pie schedule i actually
don't
but if you can hit me up with those
i might i like chick-fil-a bro in and
out
so we're gonna get into some trending
topics for the week uh the whole world
they have lost their damn mind there is
a woman uh she's a british colombian
uh she lives in seattle
and she said
she spiritually identifies as a wolf
and
like me you could have guessed it she's
a he
and she says she has to refrain
from howling in public no [ __ ] you
gotta refrain from going to jail cause
if you start howling in public
and you're in seattle you know how many
karens live in seattle your ass going to
prison
you identify as the world with all you
want in your house you can lift your leg
up and piss on the sofa but you know
better to start that [ __ ] in public in
seattle
that's why i like
there's something about seattle there's
an aura i think it's the lack of sun
y'all get it's always rainy and foggy
and cold and it just makes the people up
there go crazy every time i go to
seattle i feel like i spiritually
identify as a [ __ ] werewolf and i
want to start howling in public that's
just how seattle is
but anyway let's get on to uh kanye
so as you guys know
kanye is my dog like i'm a big kanye fan
but he
he can't take
that pete davidson is banging his ex
pete davidson must be swinging and
hanging and i mean kanye
you're too
you're getting too weird bro you wearing
them big ass boots [ __ ] everywhere
them square ass jackets
them dirty ass clothes kim was just
tired of it
but now uh
kanye said he flew like uh uh in the
middle of the night
to go meet like ray j and was it like uh
whack 100 or whatever his name is to go
get another sex tape that kim kardashian
had out with ray j
and then to top it off
kanye's out here allegedly saying pete
davidson got aids like bro come on bro
you sound like a 20 year old
get it together man let kim live her
life you can get anybody you want
you got that little bad little white
chick man have fun with that man kim is
gone bruh she for the streets
start listening in the future bruh she
is for the streets
all right man we're going to get into it
oh what's up man how you doing bro
how you doing man
you look like a south american werewolf
man your hair looks like the [ __ ] my cat
just took in the little box
bro if you don't get your ass out here
looking like a uh a [ __ ]
brazilian warlord bit
i take that man that's a compliment yo
man you still you still waiting on your
daddy to come home from the corner store
hey you look like you ain't got no teeth
at the top of your mouth get your little
put your little cat food eating somebody
got fruity that's that bro you look like
you're about to lose a foot you better
be careful and you look like a hostage
with your hands tied behind your back
it's time to have my back nervous
i seen you jumping off of the airplanes
over there and uh what was it kabu
oh yeah yeah that was remember when
biden left all the weapons over there
he was on the airplane
i was on the airplane bro
what's up bro yeah look at that little
handsome woodpecker [ __ ]
[Music]
hey
bill cosby [ __ ] your daddy right now
he might be and i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
but at least but at least my parents
don't get [ __ ] by animals
patrice oatmeal
[Laughter]
that was a good one your mama caught you
naked in the barnyard when you was 9.
sweaty back gorilla
sweaty back gorilla you just saying this
right now
you [ __ ] saying jokes off of a
goddamn can of dipping tobacco
ah it might be a redneck
hey uh they said your lips came with a
party sub
well that's diesel
they said joe they said your goatee came
with a domestic abuse allegation
[Laughter]
hey what's up david bro you look like a
bass pro shot mannequin
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] stupid man you're so dumb
even though for me this week
that's so dumb man that you're so dumb
that even your half asian kids are going
to need math tutors
okay
i know you touring the country
uh but home is where the heart is man so
you always live near full cardiac arrest
there we go
you can't train this week let's go
dude dude you just stop burning sad ass
dudes on this show and start burning
some calories oh bro i'm getting roasted
by the american sniper ain't that a
[ __ ]
you had 32 head shots in iraq
[ __ ] you
still got shrapnel in your beard [ __ ]
no i just worked on electronics your
favorite candle scent is deer pee
how do you know
[Laughter]
that [ __ ]
yeah i know you got a camouflage
recliner [ __ ]
look like bye-bye black sheep left three
bags of wool on top of your head man
[ __ ]
you live down the lane you look like a
redneck version of the mask of zorro
god damn it man
you came that's why you came you look
like you'll hold a gas station up and
only take beef jerky and potato chips
you look like the first person to get a
liver transplant in mexico
[Music]
do i go back now or what
do whatever you want go ahead
all right all right you look like uh
overweight darth vader right now
there we go what else you gotta do
what else i got you are shaped like an
eminem but the peanut one
you got you got the teeth of a racing
horse
that's a good one um
your diet consists of carrots and hay
white you look like a thick whoopie
goldberg why you over there teaching
math in armenia
hable espanol what's up man you have to
do two plus two
where you at right now bro i'm at work
actually what do you work at
i do fire and water restoration
so houses that burn down i go and i fix
them so you burn the houses down and
then you make them pay you to refix yeah
yeah you know you [ __ ] slick spanish
w
hey that's how i get connection with the
the mexican roofers yeah bro i head over
to home depot and i hang out with them
north face is exactly correct because
all mexicans know you got to run north
to get to freedom
[Laughter]
all mexicans no it's north all i know is
norse
i'm about north way let's go away
oh man you are boy pig you're shaped
like a giant eighth grader you look like
you get suicidal when it's raining it's
a little stupid [ __ ] by the way
man you look like you got big ass rolls
of hat sheesh hanging from your head
bro you look like you're allergic to
white rice little dumb ass boy what the
[ __ ] wrong with you
man i bet your computer's got cracks in
the screen and i bet you beat your mama
up over a broken skateboard wheel when
you was eight
with your [ __ ] mountain lion
face as well look at this stupid ass
what
look at you felix domestic is looking at
us
there's a little dumb ass little slatted
ass eyes boy
oh man you look like if scar from the
lion king was a better hunter you got
eyes like you only you
you look you got eyes like you only hunt
at night
it's a little dumb ass somebody here
what up bro you look like the ceo of
ikea
that's right the [ __ ] you got going on
dog
oh not much
yeah that
that that uh
that jacket you got on look like it's
made out of blended trash bags it's
members only baby yeah brad [ __ ] look
itchy as a [ __ ] boy
that look that looked like that looked
like the blanket they put around fire
victims when they get them out the house
hell yeah
you look like an emotional butcher
an emotional butcher [ __ ] green hair
bro
goddamn bro you look like a dark
chocolate marshmallow man you look like
you get emotional everybody every time
somebody asks for two pounds of steak
it looks like every time you hungry you
pull one of those chocolate twizzlers
off your head
what inspired that hair
what's that what inspired that hair
my my son your girl left you or your dog
died your sensitive [ __ ]
nah i'm just trying to relate with all
them bros that got blue balls trying to
show support
your hair look like it smell like
chewing gum
bro you got the teeth of a meth head
i ain't got the belly one
going on bro yo ass look like you
collect propane tanks [ __ ]
[ __ ] i got a few at the bed
hell yeah bro you look like you have a
skeleton as your passenger
not today
you like you got a house you like you
got a house full of small dogs bro
i got one small dog two big ass ones
how did i know y'all all eat out of the
same bowl
hey as long as i'm first it's so good
what you driving a tow truck
no i got a big ass truck i'll jump out
real quick no i don't need to see it
oh that's
that's what you put your house on every
time they try to collect the rent
ain't catching me man
all right family it's time to go
we get the [ __ ] out of here
hey what up this your boy david man
thank y'all for tuning in again and
thank you to everybody who came with
them roasts man y'all getting better bro
y'all heating up man y'all cooking now
bro y'all got me a little bit uh i'm
trying to make y'all bring that beast
out of me bro but make sure you continue
to put your jokes in the comments and
we're gonna read the best ones every
week man and thank y'all for tuning in
and i'm signing out boom